like thanks auntie and and and thanks
Dennis and hello everyone
Mitch stolt so I'm a senior staff
attorney at the Electronic Frontier
Foundation up in San Francisco how many
folks here are familiar with the FF
quite a few that's that's good that's
good to hear it's a non-profit digital
civil liberties organization founded in
1990 donor supported about 35,000 active
donors and just about 100 employees and
coming up on our 30th anniversary so
what Dennis had asked me here to talk
about in particular the Oracle versus
Google case and a little bit about the
history of it why it's probably the
biggest case to come along dealing with
the the law of software in quite a long
time so both what's happened with it and
what some of the policy questions raised
are and it's relevant now the case has
been actually been going on since since
2012 is is an eight year old Hazen not
done yet but it has finally reached the
Supreme Court which is gonna hear it
sometime this spring and could once
again upend how we think of copyright in
software particularly copyright in
software interfaces which is what the
case is about so I'm gonna talk about
that a little bit talk about some of the
questions it raises to maybe maybe take
your questions and get into a bit of
discussion about you know how we should
think of copyright and software and
legal protection for software generally
and then the folks would like to talk
about some of the some of the other
issues that e FF is working on happy to
do that too particularly around software
the freedom to innovate law about laws
about computer hacking and so on or
other cases that we're working on the
folks have heard about and want to have
a discussion about it happy to engage in
that but but but starting with Oracle
versus Google because because that is
that is a big one the FF has
participated with friend-of-the-court
briefs at every level of this case so
it's it's been it's been a consuming
issue for us as well when I was starting
a write up here was a the names of Java
code packages and those were at the
heart of the Oracle case I'll give a
little bit of the history Oracle
acquired Java along with Sun Java at
least at one point a very popular
programming language and when Google was
first developing Android it ended up
copying 37 of the 37 sets of class and
method definitions from Java from the
Java API that were ultimately
incorporated into Android they're not
compatible Android does not draw is not
Java compatible but they were building
on the knowledge and investment that
developers already had in how to write
Java programs to make it easier to write
Android apps early on now the way Sun
and then Oracle had Java licensed was a
good portion of it was available under
the GPL under the free software license
both for their own reasons didn't want
to deal with GPL code so they ended up
copying copying these without permission
not the code not the implementation just
the class of method definitions so the
the example that kept coming up in the
case was if you want to compare two
numbers use Java dot Lang dot math dot
max which will tell you the larger of
two numbers to that function nothing
about how that function was implemented
nothing but how it worked
Google did that themselves they did it
again just the bare facts of these are
the words we use to invoke that function
the words that Java programmers were
already used to using to invoke that
function that was one examples that they
were 37 of these packages they were
various figures getting for how many
lines it was similar between 7,000 and
11,000 lines but it was not
implementation it was definitions of
classes and methods nonetheless Oracle
sued Google in 2012 claiming patent
infringement and copyright infringement
and that food that was here in federal
court here in San Francisco and it went
to a jury trial and that jury throughout
the patent claims say they said there
was no patent infringement but they said
there was copyright infringement but
that not judge this is judge Alsip a
federal judge here in San Francisco who
had actually taught himself to code for
the purpose of understanding this case
better an unusual step for a federal
judge he ruled that there could not be
copyright infringement of these java
classes and methods the piece of the
java api because these just weren't
subject to copyright this was not the
same thing as copying all of java
it wasn't copying the implementation of
java it wasn't copying any of the
executable code or source code or object
code that java developers had built it
was just the definition of the interface
that programmers could use he said that
wasn't that something that was subject
to copyright at all
Oracle appealed and for this is more on
the law geek side of thing but but I'll
so took an interesting path because they
had originally been patent claims in the
in the case and there is a special
Federal Court of Appeals that handles
patent claims called the Court of
Appeals for the Federal Circuit and they
can't have done that patent cases from
all over the country
patent claims in this case had already
been dismissed but but but because they
were in there in the first place the
case went to the Federal Circuit when
the Federal Circuit said reversed the
trial judge and said actually yes api's
are subject to copyright api's are
computer programs legally there is no
difference and if you copy an API you're
caught that's a significant piece of a
computer program and that's something
that you need to get permission for
whether that means payment or through
using an existing open-source license
that's licensed under or or some other
means you had to get you had to get
permission to use those and you didn't
that's copyright infringement but he
they said it back to the trial court
unto another jury on the question of
fair use how many folks have heard the
phrase fair use regarding copyright
quite a few of you various is a really
important exception to copyright but
it's a kind of an open-ended one in
which the judge and sometimes the jury
ends up doing of a balancing test of
various factors what they used was for
what sort of copyrighted work we're
talking about how much was used and
whether it's going to cause impact on
the actual sales or markets for the
original and even though it's really
different awful often really difficult
to say beforehand the way that a fair
use claim is going to go it's really
important that it's there because fair
use is what allows a lot of
experimentation and creativity and
things that have ended up creating
really great art and really great
science and really great engineering
without asking permission first
permission that probably wouldn't have
been given especially if you had to
approach company like like Oracle that
would rather just have that innovation
happen in-house or or be paid for it
second trial
we're now in 2015
quite an interesting trial went on for
several weeks was a battle of the
metaphors an API is like the chapter and
section headings of a book no an API is
a file cabinet without the files there
were more and they they kind of went on
for weeks right oh of course an API is
all and none of those but it's to a lay
jury it's often ends up a battle of the
metaphors nonetheless the the jury in
that case decided that Google's use was
fair use that went back up to the
Federal Circuit on Oracle's second
appeal the Federal Circuit again up
ended really the expectations of most of
the software world overruled the jury
throughout the jury decision and said no
this is not fair use once again this is
copyright infringement
I didn't emphasize this before but both
of these decisions that was 2014 and
2018 kind of feel like a bomb on the
software industry because API sharing an
API re implementation has happens all
the time a lot of the most really sort
of foundational parts of the computing
world were sort of the result of
re-implementing others interfaces
whether whether it was the various
versions of the the for the UNIX
interfaces which became the POSIX
standard which became you know in all of
its forms agree implementations of with
with variations over time of the
the api's there are lots of other
examples be the solar Ria's happen all
the time and people didn't ask
permission for it and they never really
they never really believed that they
needed to and what this what these two
decisions said was reimplemented API is
something that you need permission from
from the original authors from and and
if you don't get it you're subject to
pretty significant damages copyright
damages in this case were potentially
run into the billions even in small case
they actually it's pretty easy to get
them up into the billions because they
don't actually have to be based on harm
copyright law allows for something
called statutory damages which is sort
of litigation russian roulette' it ends
up being anywhere from $200 to 150
thousand dollars per copyrighted work
without a whole lot of guidelines as to
how those get you decided on if you have
a number of works that can easily mean
bankruptcy for especially for a small
firm or an individual doing this this
sort of experimentation or trying to
build something new
question was we will stipulate early on
the the apos were copyrightable they
they may have made they may have made
some statements early on but you didn't
affect the cod the the progress of the
case the case was no two issues first
our API is something that you can
copyright and then was assuming they
were was it still was it fair use to you
to use an API without permission we
implement an API without permission to
build something new yeah when was was
the creation of the PC BIOS considered a
valid precedent in these cases forth
lowers precedent generally means things
that have gone to courts did that was
that was there a looser case on that
so I'll repeat some whenever the folks
online no if I could summarize the the
the gentleman said the there was
litigation over the PC BIOS which
resulted in a decision that said a
cleanroom
re implementation of the PC BIOS was not
copyright infringement
that was absolutely raised in all of
these cases it was raised as president
along with a number of others there
another another couple of other
foundational cases a couple were from
the early 1990s about video game
emulators companies that had
re-implemented the interface for old
console video game machines in order to
play their games on a PC or vice versa
so I simply re-implemented it to build
games without the permission of the
console manufacturer and in both of
those cases the court said that's okay
particularly because you're doing it to
create something new and you're copying
no more than the the know-how again
today we call an API the the the the
know-how for coding new games or a new
platform for games to the existing
interface and the other one was about
the
menu tree on the old Lotus 1-2-3
spreadsheet and they macro language that
people use to automate spreadsheet tasks
in Lotus of cases called Lotus versus
Borland and that Borland had used
lotuses met macro language in its own
spreadsheet program the court said that
was ok to the and the reasons we're
interesting I'm going to get into this a
little bit because it because it's at
the heart of the the Oracle case as well
and I think it's the fun of it it's one
of the fundamental questions here is
interfaces api's you know their various
descriptions and it and it is a bit
slippery but something that but but but
things that allow for interoperability
between programs or allow for creating
new programs are not really the same
thing as an implementation which is
where the cases that you mentioned come
in those cleanroom reimplementation zuv
the pc bios were I would say comparable
to what Google did in using the class of
method definitions but not the
implementation and probably under the
Federal Circuit's decisions in the
Oracle case you know IBM would have kept
control of the PC BIOS and Microsoft
would never have gotten off the ground
and then we'd be living in a very
different world
it's copyrighted
[Music]
the question was what it was was about
the ownership of SQL are these being one
of the crown jewels of Oracle you know
there others have implemented that a
MySQL is questions is what's gonna
happen with standards bodies it's a it's
a it's a really good question and I'd
like to defer it because I wanted again
it kind of kind of get into some of the
questions raised by the Oracle versus
Google case and then that with that one
I think it's kind of an upshot of all of
these as what does this mean for
technical standards and software or even
on hardware for that matter let me go a
little bit deeper and say you know if
you could take you into a little bit of
log E career at copyright applies to
software but it's never been a really
good fit strictly speaking when you're
talking about copyright software is
considered a literary work which I know
that got some chuckles for the from that
so it's it's it's a little weird right
so copying an entire software program
source code or object code in many
circumstances without various exceptions
and justifications right it's it's
pretty easy to see that that's copyright
infringement in many in many cases and
under those circumstances it makes sense
to apply copyright to software
you also have patents now you didn't
originally it was it was copyrighted
software happened earlier than Pattinson
software but even earlier on and and and
even with the addition of patents there
was the recognition in the courts and
certainly in the software industry that
some kinds of copying were ok or they
had to be ok or everything was going to
a halt copyright doesn't cover ideas it
raises this somewhat metaphysical
distinction between ideas on one hand
you have ideas systems methods processes
procedures that's on one hand on the
other hand you have creative expression
and creative expression that's that's
the world of copyright comes from so the
the creativity that goes into music or
literature or photography or visual art
or so on but what does that mean in
software where do we draw this line
between the creativity I think we'd all
agree that the software engineering can
be creative but where's the line between
what that what's creative and what is an
idea process system method procedure and
why draw that line one of the reasons is
reuse the holy grail of software
engineering reuse maybe not necessarily
requiring permission now what can even
be owned some of these things then crash
into patents so you think if they're a
method or a process those are things
that classically and now with software
as well can be patented you can patent a
process for achieving a result
method for making something so copyright
then excludes those things and then some
things just just aren't subject to
property at all so copyright leaves out
things that either are best handled by
patents or that just shouldn't be owned
at all and the question in the in in the
software world my questions raised by
this case are you know what is that
what's what should be owned and what
shouldn't what what makes sense so a
couple of things that really they issues
that that came up in this case that get
that this was this is being argued to
the Supreme Court right now they turned
it down the the first go-around they've
accepted it the second time after after
eight years of this case that means at
least four of the nine justices
something in it that they wanted to
review it doesn't really say anything
about how they're going to review it and
it's pretty hard to predict but some of
the things that have come up and the is
you know our API is the same thing as
computer programs or our API is such a
significant piece of a computer program
that it they ought to get the same
protection how much should the ability
to reuse to have they specifically the
ability to re-implement an API how much
should that matter to be able to do that
without permission
and and then the other one is how to
account for for network effects
copyright is based on the ideal idea
that people should be compensated for
their creativity you've you created some
original work of literature or visual
arts or music or sculpture or
choreography you and you share that with
the world
you should be compensated for that but
when we're talking about API is the
value often lies not in at some point
anyway not in the creativity that went
into making them or even sometimes the
technical merit but just how often
they're used this ties into the
standards question so I want to get to
that but Google argued in this case and
EF F did as well that it wasn't so much
Sun and Oracles
efforts that made the Java API valuable
it was the computing world's investment
and learning had a code to that API and
that wasn't so much because of its merit
as more as its ubiquity Network effects
the more people using it the more value
it is the more valuable it is regardless
of its technical merit or its creativity
and if that's the case then maybe it
isn't something that should be owned
that's the the argument raised there now
Oracle has raised good arguments as well
and it has has succeeded twice before
the the Federal Circuit on this case I
was going back to your earlier question
about precedent the the Federal Circuit
which again mostly handles patent cases
has an unfortunate tendency to twist
precedent they don't ignore it but they
read into it what others don't
especially interesting in this copyright
case because it isn't there
regular area they don't usually get
copyright cases sort of an unusual set
of circumstances that led to them
hearing a copyright case and because of
that they were supposed to apply the law
created by the other federal appeals
courts like the Ninth Circuit which yeah
which is here in California and the
Ninth Circuit had already said the
copyright favors reuse and
reimplementation particularly to create
something new rather than just to
reproduce something already made but
they read that a little differently and
they said no we don't we don't we don't
see it that way because there's not
legally a distinction between an API and
a program this thing they they used this
phrase at Oracle was using as they call
this declaring code I don't think that's
too common a phrase in the industry
you'd say declarations maybe they're
you'd say header files but they call the
declaring code as a way of saying that
there's that there's not a difference
between between declarations and
implementation it's all code and if you
use someone else's code you need
permission that's that's what that's
what the Federal Circuit said and then
let's know the weight on the other side
of the scale here and because there
certainly there can be technical merit
to an API there can be more there may be
eyes are more useful than others you
could even say Java was successful
because of its ingenuity and that itself
you know deserves a reward and reusing
that ingenuity without permission is
wrong
[Music]
there's a great question sounds like
you're describing a very strict
cleanroom implementation of an API so
it's possible we don't know yet law
works iteratively and that weren't and
that's not that there wasn't there
wasn't the facts of this case now we
have we have we have the earlier cases
we have eight we do have the pc bios and
and so on that said you know if you
really come in with zero knowledge if
you completely you know using
experimentation right a completely
original piece of software perhaps you
know you know that happens to be binary
compatible with an existing service and
you haven't copied anything it's an
easier case actually that that is likely
not copyright infringement even in this
you know even under even under or in an
Oracle's world even in the federal
circuit's world that's pretty hard
and that's not something that on the
scale of its probably yes basic fact of
copyright and this again is coming from
the world of literature and and film and
photography and so on is if you never
saw their original you can't have copied
it and if you really can implement
interface never having seen the server
code oh but see right if you if you
bought you both a book and read it
that's under copyright that there's
that's you have you've had access to it
and the question yeah book of recipes
but but the question in this case and
the question that comes up is did you
take too much that's and and and that's
what that's where the line drawing
occurs and and it doesn't map cleanly to
a lot of software engineers
understandings of the difference between
an interface and implementation it
should there's a way to do that and
hopefully that's that's what we're
moving towards but but if you but if
you've read that book you then you are
not in the clear anymore
but recipes right he said it's free to
use recipes and a cookbook that with
that gets that gets into the question of
when if you taken so much under
copyright you are free to use recipes in
a cookbook but not to copy too much of
the creativity that went into the words
of the recipe
how much software is a software is text
in a sense special we're talking about
source code so yeah so what they did was
they wrote it down and self-published
create a publishing company publish the
book and therefore the code is
transmitted
and that copyright was recognized and
accepted and then if you actually sat
down and the question was how is
software copyrighted today the last
complete overhaul of our copyright law
was passed in 1976 became law in 1978
and it had a few changes relating to
software copyright in the early 1980s
and since then copyright is automatic
this is like a lot of folks don't
realize this but you you scribble a note
on a napkin
it has copyright you take a photograph
it has copyright and if you write code
oh but the most simple bits of
[Music]
implementation at least have copyright
as soon as you set them down you don't
have to publish them in a book and you
don't have to register them with any
government agency you get certain
benefits for doing so you actually have
to register it before you file a lawsuit
but copyright is automatic from as soon
as you set it down
question was when you register do you
have to demonstrate the creation date
you you have to give them a creation
date you don't have to give them
evidence in the form of a published book
[Music]
the question is is how our priority
challenges resolved any kind of evidence
comes in on that it's not it's no longer
a matter of formality like I made it to
the Copyright Office first or or I
published a book first those sorts of
questions and copyright land as opposed
to patent well the patent is moving that
direction to but but but they get
resolved in court and the court will
look at whatever whatever evidence you
can bring in of when you first set it
down on paper and that actually is the
date that network or or on are on a hard
drive and that's actually the date that
matters
question is is this case in there any
dispute over what was copyrighted and
when not really both sides and nearly
everyone involved acknowledges that son
wrote Java and that Oracle owns the
copyrights in Java the question that the
question is is is is a narrower one of
is the API part of something that can be
copyrighted or does it fall outside an
ad that's our question over here
question GU the question was was was how
did this compare to to apples legal
campaign against against Mac clones
basically right
so the question was whether there was
some there may have been some text
string in the Mac OS or previous
versions of that that was that would be
creative on those copyrighted yeah yeah
a lot of folks over the years have tried
to sort of put little copyright traps
into things that wouldn't otherwise be
copyrighted this is this came up in in
luxury watches that they would catch a
copyrighted design onto the back of them
and use try to use that copyright claim
to prevent importation of the gray
market importation of those watches the
Supreme Court ultimately said that was
that that was okay the importation was
okay or essentially that's not what
copyright is for more Apple more broadly
I don't think the precise question about
re-implementing an API ever came up
because I as as far as I know all of
those Mac clones
this is mostly I think in the 90s was in
the era was it was was this happen as
they were copying code they were copying
they were copying implementation from
Apple going back to those goods this
question about difficulty I I don't know
that anyone successfully achieved a
clean room a perfect clean room
reimplementation of an Apple operating
system
but alas on Parker it wasn't because
because it clearly on the operating
system so so can you
the club is this requires an operating
system and a manufacturer and things
start something separate your hardware
manufacturer and they that's right it
was it was that what you were referred
to it's a licensing issue you said that
Apple could could simply refused to
license its software to run on on
non-apple hardware and that's that's a
it's another key question and software
copyright honestly and it it's but could
spend another hour on that but but this
notion that you always need a license
ready because in loading loading a
program into RAM is making a copy of it
under what so so so so that gets into so
so so you you know you need the
copyright holders permission just to do
that that that's that's raises another
set of issues
to API based on inside a single
processor or memory system question was
that they've been thought put into
things like web interfaces interfaces
that are not occurring on a single
processor but that are that are
occurring over networks a lot of folks
are worried about that and the way that
the Federal Circuit decisions were
written absolutely implicates that it
wasn't the facts of this case but that
seems to be very much at risk now and I
think the legal departments of a lot of
software companies or have been kind of
a bit frantic for the past few years
about what this is going to mean have
been follow-on lawsuits by the way not a
flood of them but they're definitely
been follow-on lawsuits by other folks
claiming copyright and api's and
claiming the right to stop
reimplementation zuv their api so this
this is happening elsewhere there's not
a clean way to distinguish API is on us
that are running that are an interface
between software running on a single
processor and an interface between
programs running across a network
there's not a there's not there's not a
clean way to distinguish those in the
law as we have it right now
another question is is there a way to
protect internal api's that are not
exposed to the public those can be trade
secrets and trade secret is is a
different beast than copyright the
classic example of a trade secret is the
formula for coca-cola if that had been
patented it it would have become public
domain sometime in the 19th century but
because they've managed to keep it a
secret until now they they have legal
tools at their disposal to protect that
secrets the same could be true of a
non-public API the exception when you're
talking about trade secrets is that
reverse engineering through means that
don't involve any sort of corporate
espionage getting back to clean room in
a clean room reverse engineering of you
know look at you can look at the binary
you can look at the chip you can strip
the chip so on and so forth is all ok
that's not considered improper means
when we're in trade secret land and some
folks try to that's a problem for some
folks and not for others you also have
patents and patents can in some
circumstances cover api's no no it's
it's appreciated ayah log
yeah the question was was the talking
about the concept of extending legal
rights over software with a minor change
that does happen in patent land patents
do pens do last 20 years copyrights in
the corporate context last 95 years so
no piece of software or the copy on that
was written for a digital computer has
yet expired some of them have maybe have
been given to the public domain but but
the copyrights but no copyrights have
actually expired yet though the
copyrights the last coverage to expire
just this past New Year's were from 1924
so but but but but but to get at your
question we are starting to see that
with things like literature and it does
happen in copyright land too so so the
court said for example there was a
copyright infringement case about
writing new Sherlock Holmes stories and
whether those violated the copyrights on
the original Arthur Conan Doyle books
and the court said well the since the
first of those books are now out of
copyright but the latter ones are not
you can write new Sherlock Holmes
stories you just can't use any aspects
of the character or plots that come from
the latest books and and and that
absolutely is used right probably will
be used in software land too and and of
course we think about we think about
embrace and extend we think about the
evolution of a standard or an API you
can certainly the entities in control of
it whether that's a standards body or or
a single company or a couple of
companies can change it a little bit
over time to make other versions
incompatible
or at least less functional and in doing
so yeah they have a new copyright and
the copyright in those changes will last
longer so the problem you're describing
is very real it's just copyright terms
are already so long that we haven't
reached it yet
that's right the question was about
patents and a lot of a lot of pretty
foundational elements of user interfaces
and and so on we're patented at one
point and those patents have now expired
yeah patent plus twenty years when
they're expired you the world can do
them that's the park and the bargain is
twenty years of exclusivity to make
money off of and then your invention
belongs to the world the other question
then is sure those things have been
patented in the first place that's we
could spend many hours on that and it's
uh another sort of fascinating
conversations about what about what
should be patented but I think should
probably mostly stay at copyright land
too often yes yes yes patents patents
can be challenged if if if the invention
wasn't in fact new if someone else that
don't if someone else had done it
earlier and you can show that
who said you could have a vortex this
court cases children
oh yeah that's right yeah I mentioned
gore-tex is another example of a trade
secret that's right you could have a
patent it at all you can you can patent
a a an original material yeah two more
questions and then I think I'm gonna
move on to a related
really good question the question was if
if a copyright owner puts their work in
the public domain can they snatch it
back out of the public domain
surprisingly law is not totally clear on
that especially outside the US probably
once you've put something in the public
domain the world is entitled to rely on
that that you've said that so I put
version 1 of my software I dedicated to
the public domain and I say that
publicly
anyone who's free to copy version 1 of
my software edit it build upon it
release new versions on their own little
less clear in other countries where
copyright is more considerate what's
called a moral right something that you
can't give away and it comes up in one
interesting context in US law and that's
it's variously called terminations or
reversions
this was a clause meant to protect
artists who sold their copyrights to
publishers or others when they were
young and poor and later when they
become world famous and successful you'd
say it's a mechanism that allows them to
reclaim their copyrights from whoever
they sold them to earlier and it's it
can happen in a five year window
I believe it's 30 to 35 years after
first publication this was invented in
the 1976 law took effect in 1978 so they
were actually only just into the 30 year
window a few years into the thirty into
the thirty or window for stuff that was
created in the 70s and some musicians
have been using that to reclaim their
copyrights from record labels for
example some original comic comic book
artists and their heirs have used it to
reclaim some copyrights
publishers I'm not aware of it happening
yet in software because you know III go
nope nobody's really suing over 30 year
old copyrights that often but it's gonna
come up and it's gonna come up
eventually and then and then we have
this interesting question of whether if
something has been put into the public
domain by a later owner whether the
original owner can snatch it back it
hasn't come up yet it's gonna be really
interesting when it does yeah
well like any lawyer would tell you
that's not kosher the question was with
taking an article and you took her
article put it on another website and
said that it was dedicated to the public
domain it's not just just just saying
the words doesn't make it so if you
didn't have the right to do that in the
first place
so the question was with somebody
contributing code to and to an
open-source project that they didn't
actually have the right to contribute
because the someone else on the
copyright and and didn't want to
contribute it you these things happen
and then in and it can be tricky for
others to be certain that all the right
permissions were granted for the most
part in the open source free software
worlds there been a few court cases but
but but those are really largely kind of
have been handled by community norms and
and and pressure and quiet negotiations
they've been it's rarely gone to court
and then that's that's more cuz that's
that that's more cultural phenomenon
than anything but it but it also means
we don't have these sort of official
decisions about you know what the law is
and in those circumstances like last
question
issues you know the issue of I'm really
glad you asked that because it's segues
into the other subject I wanted to spend
the last 15 minutes on we have till till
quarter out varieties a and the question
was about legal protection for hardware
interfaces but but also for for issues
like car repair or repair of physical
devices copyright generally doesn't
apply to physical so the shape of
physical objects except in some some
rare circumstances and it doesn't apply
to functional objects like a crash bar
on the door or it was was your example
or they the physical shape of a cable
connector to the two car parts those and
sometimes we covered by patents and as
you mentioned the merger doctrine okay I
didn't know the technical term but that
but that is that is right at the heart
of the Oracle case it is is does the
even you know even assuming that there
is that there is creativity in in this
case an API does does that creativity
merge with the functionality again we're
really kind of getting into metaphysics
but that's why it's it's sort of a fun
area of law because we do get these
metaphysical questions this is the
creativity merge with the functionality
the Federal Circuit said no I think they
said as long as they were multiple
is to do it the creativity doesn't merge
with the functionality it's really it's
it's a very narrow interpretation of
that idea it's is the one that the one
the Federal Circuit used was they didn't
have to call it they didn't have to call
it java.lang math.max they could have
called it arithmetic dot larger and it
would have had the same function because
there were multiple ways they could have
done it it's creative and thus they can
prevent copying that leaves out the
entire discussion of the value of
interoperability the value of reuse and
who's creating the value we is it was it
the original creator or was it that
wasn't really the people who use it and
that's sort of turn it into something
they've all invested in those that
narrow definition of them of merger
leaves that out and and as we pointed
out because that could come up in a
physical interface to it but but
typically that's gonna be patent and not
copyright the the one of us to segue
into talking about another law that
vexes software developers and also
repair people so you'd mentioned car
repair and printer cartridges and and so
on and that's cuz known as the
anti-circumvention law or in section
1201 of the Digital Millennium Copyright
Act you'll often hear the phrase is
technical protection measure or TPM used
in this context well this was an add-on
a separate body of legal thought that
was created in the 1990s so this was law
in the u.s. in 1998 in Europe shortly
after that and in many developed
countries that but after that but not
all there there are
at least a number of technically
sophisticated countries that don't have
this but the idea is if you have any
sort of copywriter to work whether
that's the use of traditional creative
work like music literature or so on or
software if you put some sort of
effective access control on it that
prevents people from accessing it or
copy or copying it this sort of two
strains that are we talking about an
access control or a copy control but
some kind of technical measure that
makes it difficult to access or copy
something some legal protection attaches
to that and it becomes illegal to break
that protection because someone might
then copy it copy they out the the
creative work or the software illegally
but it's separately illegal just to
break the protection so this was again a
concept created 22 years ago in US law
had all kind of weird spillover effects
or maybe not so weird in terms of
whether they were intended the the the
paradigm in the 90s was the encryption
on DVD is or various encryption schemes
that have been proposed for digital
music back then none of which had any
success in the market DVDs did and and
the notion was will encrypt DVDs it
wasn't a complex encryption it was it
was fairly simple it was forget exactly
how long the the the the code was but I
remember it fit on a t-shirt it was just
a few lines of code could encrypt the
DVD but because they applied encryption
breaking that encryption without the
permission of the rights holder
of the technology vendor was separately
illegal and they put in some exceptions
that ultimately weren't all that useful
to people and then there is a process
that occurs at the US Copyright Office
every three years where people can come
in and ask for exceptions the
interesting and I say that word with
with with a grain of irony because
because really it's pretty troublesome
but many of the problems have come up
many of them have come up in the
traditional media because because this
law interferes with creative reuse of
video for example in music but in the
software world what it cement is you you
slap some sort of access control on your
software or hardware and you gain this
very powerful legal tool that prevents
interoperability also sometimes prevents
repair prevents security research there
are there are exceptions for the repair
and security research the ones that were
built into the law have ended up being
so narrow and subjective that they're
almost never used people just haven't
been able to trust that they're actually
going to be shielded from lawsuits by
trying to rely on these it's it's
absolutely big issue in voting machines
the various vendors of electronic voting
machines have made DMCA 1201 claims to
try to actually stop independent
security research in recent years in the
3-year exemption process we've we've
managed to convince the US Copyright
Office to grant somewhat broader
exceptions for security research and for
repair not for tinkering or
experimentation more generally
even where there's no underlying
copyright infringement they've always
said that it's a separate thing just
breaking the encryption or it is always
encryption but that's but that's it
it often is it could be simply by
passing a password check in some cases
but the level of sophistication doesn't
have to be high to trigger the
application of this law but it's been a
real problem for you know before I can
transfer for computer security and for
repair it's been claimed you know on the
the interface between printer cartridges
and printers actually that was it was a
rare case when it wasn't successful it's
been claimed the radio protocol for a
universal garage door opener they
whatever the handshake the radio
handshake is between the garage door
remote and and and the opener it is it
has all good has often been claimed
against security researchers including
one who was famously arrested after
giving a talk this is a while back and
the other we really significant problem
is that these exceptions that we get and
got every three years they only apply to
actually doing the circumvention but
they don't apply to making tools the law
basically assumes that everybody can
roll their own decryption their own
tools because creating or distributing
the tools to do it he's often illegal
even if doing it do we doing the
circumventing the access control is not
I did not
talking about printing the the DCSS the
the DVD decryption code in a book you
know my my colleague Andy FF says shown
wrote a version of the DCSS algorithm as
a haiku as a proof of concept that code
is expressive and should be our first
amendment protection EMF is engaged in a
legal challenge to the DMCA in its
entirety based on the First Amendment's
our clients and in that case are a
security researcher and an entrepreneur
and their claim is that this
anti-circumvention law particularly the
trafficking provision of this that's
what it's called but the creation and
distribution of decryption tools or and
so on the clause making that illegal is
an unacceptable restraint on speech and
even the 3-year exemption process at the
Copyright Office is an impermissible
speech licensing regime and we cleared
the first hurdle in that case the the
the the court said that we have stated a
potentially stated a violation of the
First Amendment and that we're entitled
to proceed and and and who to prove it
so well we'll see how that goes but the
but but there are there are very
significant free speech you know
implications for this going back to the
case in the in in the 90s that's a code
is speech and certainly
teaching others how to code something is
speech question has it relate to the API
dispute so not directly this was not
raised in the Oracle case the way it
relates is this law section 1201 is
another method that is sometimes used to
lock down API is in the broad sense it's
it's a lock down compatibility so
there's so so to prevent the use of
generic or remanufactured ink cartridges
and a printer by by putting an access
control on the API between the cartridge
and the printer so it's it's an
additional layer of legal hurdles that
did that didn't even come up in the in
the Oracle case but it comes up a lot in
the automotive context because the
software in vehicles very often is
subject to some sort of access control
it's it's made difficult to dump the
code from from from a car and in some
circumstances trying to get at the even
even the the the the interfaces to the
to the canvas and a vehicle might
potentially involve circumventing an
access control and that's used of course
to enforce restrictions on who can
repair cars it's it's it's used to drive
people to expensive factory authorized
repair and away from independent repair
it's used to conceal security flaws in
some cases or so yeah
that wall then you still have an API and
the question was even without section
1201 do you you you're still faced with
with various AP is that you have to
interface with to connect devices to a
vehicle and and and with that and
require a license fee that's going to
depend on the outlet on the outcome of
the the Oracle case I mean we we we get
we come right we come we come that we
come right back to to these issues or
about about whether whether it's legal
to re-implement an interface without
permission from copyright owner we're
just about a time I can take a couple
more questions I guess but otherwise I
and I'll stick around a little while
afterwards - you mentioned farmers and
tractors absolutely john deere has been
particularly vocal and litigious about
limiting access to their tractors it's
made a splash so was to rulemaking
cycles ago so it so it was 2015 when
they made the claim in public that they
were worried about people pirating music
on their $300,000 tractor
relatedly and I've just read a report
that old John Deere tractors are in such
high demand that they're actually more
expensive in some cases than new ones
and that's because they can be
independently repaired and the new ones
can't so this has very real economic
implications
well that goose is wise Oracle suing
Google in the first place there is a lot
of money at stake this is if if if
Oracle is successful it's a it's a multi
billion dollar judgment quite quite
possibly and I have to imagine he's
weigh that against the the free
marketing if you will or the benefit
that comes from having even more people
writing Java by virtue of writing
Android absent and learning that API and
having that API become more of a more
ubiquitous and even become a standard
and probably keep probably keep Java
alive for another decade these are these
are considerations that any software
company can and probably should have
it's valuable to be the originator of a
ubiquitous API even if you can't control
every use of it ultimately probably more
valuable but that's where we are and not
everyone agrees
obviously an amazed at how many people
go up to something inside the black box
and explore it how do these people
discover the voltage over which if I
understand the question is is Oracle is
it is Oracle claiming the how far how
far that claim is their their claim
revolves around Google using these 27
header files again going back to the
Googler we said if if you actually never
saw the original code or even read a
description of it if you if you really
are doing it doing a cleanroom if you if
all you have is a black box or a chip or
something and you are simply throwing
random input at it and you find input
that allows you to interface
meaningfully with it
there is no copyright problem there
could still be a patent problem but
there is no copyright problem but but
from my point of view from the lawyer's
point of view that rarely comes out
I would say yes the the question was is
there case law that says completely
clean reimplementation he's not
copyright infringement there is and
there are cases from outside the
software world that say if you you come
up with a story about you know a boy who
discovers he's a wizard and goes off to
magical school but you've never actually
read Harry Potter you're fine I think
we're a time but thank you all and I
will stick around